hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast antimicrobial resistance
identification strain typing and assay
design with CLC genomics workbench
presented by women Widow verts senior
scientist microbial genomics kyochon I
am Alexis Krause of lab roots and I will
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kaya gen for more
information about our sponsor please
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us note that you're having a
problem
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Ritter Berg I
will now turn the presentation over to
her
thank you for that introduction as we
all know whole genome sequencing is
becoming a standard for investigating
exterior life so it's a range of
applications
from clinical microbiology and food
safety to Salem the correctly
identifying a pathogen learn of the
subtypes and any potential resistance
markers can all be in seneschal for
monitoring and pathogens so pageant
mathematics offers a comprehensive set
of tools from our Cougars now and today
during the session I will demonstrate
the tools needed for analyzing whole
genome sequencing data from pathogens
for taxonomic identification of an
accident
assigning a sequence type detecting X
microbial resistance markers and tracing
an outbreak BS myth based analysis
so for demonstration purposes we have
chosen to study evaluation of 14 on
sequencing about read section of someone
and observer which has been published in
plus one
someone is common cause of infectious
diseases the genius is divided into
Salmonella from Gauri and Salmonella
enterica Salmonella enterica alone has
more than 2,500 different serotypes get
over and drive it is so that samarium
are the cause of uncertainty five-cent
of all humans some online fictions
the study we have chosen for
demonstration spring from a Danish
laboratory still a few my
gastrointestinal infection over tenure
and it describes the collection of forty
seven seven alliances so that it
contains I switch from six ships and
outbreaks cut a number of unrelated
background excellent but for this
demonstration in the interest of time we
have selected just cyclist
all of the data analysis will be
performed with the NC genomics workbench
and the CSE microbial genomics module
so I know many of you are probably
familiar but I'll just quickly introduce
our software solution which supports
analysis in the areas of genomics
molecular biology message analysis I
think if it's genomics and transcription
but the call we have the CFCs Network
French which can be extended with plugin
for example we have the sluggy PLC
module with an action module which
contains also for macroeconomics
enabling microbiome analysis and
pathogen shaping
the clucking sgmckee know finishing
module contains tools acquired for
producing high-quality genome assemblies
and reference genomes
we collaborate with external partners to
provide our users with the
functionalities of Cosmos IDs meta-gene
mac and plastic go
solution is fully scalable to meet any
sample person so you can run your
analysis clock on or through our genomic
server
I'll demonstrate how to use our tools to
analyze whole genome sequencing data
using their deformation case has someone
ever
funeral steps I will go through signing
acts economy to the isolate finding they
want to look at sequence nights
investigate the phylogenetic
relationships of the accident and
finally to look for microbial
persecution but before we can get
started on the analysis we need to do a
bit of setup
so we will need to import our sequencing
data we will import any media data we
have available and then we will set up
what we call a result metadata table
which is essentially a table that will
ending the drawer read data any metadata
and also all of the result files that we
generate
so I will now switch to to a live demo
you
okay so this is what our
CLC genomics work in Scripture so at the
very stuff we have the navigation area
with travel system where you can store
all of your input itself and then down
here at the bottom we have a tool box
with all of the tools that you can use
so the tool box can also be found up
here at the top containing all of the
available tools
so for this demonstration we are going
to use the micro dynamics module so
whenever you're still plugging it was to
work with the tools for that plugin in
one of these solar scriptures
so the first thing we need to do is to
curve data
so for that we will click on import and
as you can see that range of sequence
files supported and in this case it's
Illumina data
so here you would specify the file path
to your sequencing file and you can
select the paired read options and and
the paired read information so I won't
do this now I have already loaded the
data and you can just take a look at you
and so I created I created a folder for
this demo called Salmonella and then the
reads are here so as you can see we have
five reasons why for each of the seven
that I select select in your program
work with the next thing we need to do
is to import metadata that will describe
all of the experts so again go to the
import and go to the import metadata so
up here it will found us to specify
spreadsheet and I have put mine other
desktop
and as soon as we have selected the
metadata spreadsheet we can see we can
see the the information from
spreadsheets window so going next then
we need to specify where our raw data is
located in their file system so we want
to select the 5/3 file
and then here we can select either an
exact or a partial match so this will
evil if the choice one dependent on
undulating of the rebound on the files
in the video datasheet but here we can
select the exact and then we need to
specify what we want to save the
metadata sheet
so it opens up here you can see beta
beta G 2 so if I don't think we need to
so we're ready to start the analysis is
to set up a result metadata table so we
will go to the macro wikinomics module
we will go to typing and epidemiology
and now here we have self metadata
folder and we will click on create
velveeta data table
so we need to select our metadata table
and this is already been selected
then we need to say pay and we need to
specify what you want to save it click
finish and it's raising late so if we
open the meter data table per meter data
to some table you can see at this minute
it's that it's empty so we will click
add normal sample and there we go the
five samples that has been specified in
our metadata table has now been put into
the resort community table
so if we select all five samples we can
say as find associated data and you can
see here that there are five five
elements associated with this metadata
and DF has the role of sample which
means that if these are the role the
role itself so we will just need to save
it and then we are ready to go
okay so we'll just go back to the
presentation
ah
okay so the first thing we want to do
analysis wide is to do a section on
assignment for these five excellence so
we will start by trimming the sequences
then we will need to download a passage
a reference database in order to a
science economy and then from this
reference database we will find the best
matching reference and the shot from
this will be a list of taxonomy of the
closest rideth related genome and also a
list potential kinetic contaminants so I
will now go back to the live
demonstration
okay so as I mentioned the first thing
we need to do is to trim the reed so we
will go to the toolbox and this is one
of our core tools the will go to NGS
cotton and fun to work not really
then we will submit by the five samples
which we won our from the read and we
remember to click the batch option
otherwise acceptable think that these
five sequencing files belong to it to
just one night of it so the better
option
here we can specify the parameters for
the quality trimming we will leave it a
default and here yeah if if we could we
could specify an adapter list but we
won't do this on
okay and we just need to specify what we
want to say this so I want to create a
new folder
come on trimming sweet
okay I'm movin out so at least in there
so this is now the type of over here
culturally and we have we have the file
and we have trailing the book we can
also go to the result innovative table
and click the refresh button and you can
now see that it has added as well as
channel elements so we now also have a
stream green and we have trimming
reports so if we're going to trim in the
pool
this will simply tell you how many weeks
were in the original file Harmon agreed
to trim and the linkage after cleaning
so now we have Trimboli now what we need
to do now is to download a positive
reference database and we have a number
of tools I can do this I will just show
one more for this demo so go to
databases in the October genomics module
we have taxonomic analysis and as you
can see there are different options but
for now we will select download pathogen
references
so here you can see we download directly
from NCBI as a from last week from the
pathogen section country so here we can
select pathogens and we can specify the
specific organism from which we want to
download data so this takes a bit of
time which we can't do this presentation
so I have already downloaded the
database and I can share with it I have
saved over lives in and a local
reference and here we have a list
downloaded 7 inhalation
now we need to assign taxonomy to the
five isolates and we will use the tool
called find best matches using clear
inscription we have other tools like
taxonomic profile that I will use use
this cameo based tool for this animal so
we need to select the trim grief
and again we need to specify that this
is a batch of five mindfulness so is now
run analysis on all type samples in one
go
here we can get by reference we want to
use so if you go into the reference
bowler and we will select the reference
database that we downloaded previously
and then you can also specify the km in
length and the index
okay and we want to define that order
for putting the users often and I will
just call it sexual
so what we can see down here at bottom
boy we have selected a tool box that's
also a process bar
where we can follow follow the process
of any tools were running so we can see
that if it's a con so that was the chest
sample done so if we click refresh and
the sub- table it will add the new
results from this analysis and you
should see it will it will give you a
best match sequences of the best match
it will click table it will prove the
quality report which will also contain
any information on potential
contamination and then absolutely it has
used English spectrum to select the best
reference it will then map the reads
after that selectively this reference
so if we for example go to this quality
report while training for success and
running you can see that for this
results about 94 percent of the risk
maps to this reference hmm
we can also see the others coverage and
the percentage of the reference sources
so
[Music]
so if you saw some of your cat
assemblé
so in addition what gets me to wait for
it to run free disease the final
sentence
okay I want to I want to hear you this
sample city to deport people to you so
as you can see we have 49% of the reefs
mapping to this someone elephants but as
you can also see we have 41% of the
reefs mapping to survive which means
that in this particular example there is
continuation from Paris
so if we now take a look at all of the
victims and the different reports on us
inmate we can ask that this sample
ending with number 12 so that one is
matching due to this particular
reference while the other one down here
is matching another reference
as you can see they are not not matching
the same reference so it's not a it's
not a single clade of someone out of
Mooji languages
okay so going back to the presentation
so the next thing we want to do is to
assign and what we know this sequence
type to the to the Salmonella isolate
and the input for this penalty tool will
be the reads mapping to the best
matching reference identifies just
previously they will need to improve a
bit on the mapping to ensure that our
results are reliable so we will do some
local realignment then we need to
download the MRC scheme we have direct
access to all schemes available at
optimality directly from within a
software and then finally we need to
assign a sequence type so this will give
us the the MOC loci identified and it
will also act with the read mapping to
each two particular sign
so switching back to to the live demo
okay so as I mentioned the input for the
NGS the monkey tool is a great mapping
file and so we will need to do a local
realignment so we will go to the toolbox
and this is one of our engineers code
tool we will select local realignment
so this results in review so we have the
mapping the read nothing phone and in
the HS of time I'll just show this so
one either it can also be a form of the
batch but it will take a bit longer okay
so everything scientists make sure that
decreases standard I'll read nothing is
selected you
okay and we will create a new folder for
all of the results related to MOC and
click finish
so we go up to the MSP folder we now
have our realigned mapping files and as
you can see the file name now got an
extension so it's now called locally
really so two column proof the nothing
we will call engines and structure
ordering so this is part of our
resequencing announced to the google
sign of your code in their instructions
and we will now the next the locally
realigned mapping file
and we will save it in the same folder
and the final thing we will do is then
use the information from the in their
file so as you can see in execution
use-value example if in delphi they will
go to another decimal realignment on the
already aligned
they already look at it real and MapInfo
but this time we'll de mess up at the
guidance very attract we will select the
the in deal file that which is created
and save it in the bhakti for
and this will give us a much improved
laughing file that we can then use to
tickle the mosquito season so what we'll
need to do before we can use 0 C 2 is to
download and mlst reference database so
we could go again on that and Emma
clovers in amis module and go to
databases
that's an NGS mlst folder and we can say
download a multi-screen the ryokan is
tool because this is the list containing
I want to be available
these teams from Pokemon asleep and we
will select Salmonella enterica the
first finish
and it will open our token DMO to themes
so you can see the different readings
and obviously on sanyas so I guess I'll
just say this
tomorrow from Seoul
this is where we put it so here can
happy that we have saved file called
seven and up there again is that also
see that is interesting marked with the
date that it was sounded so we can
always keep track on which version of
the downloaded it must've seen real
working but if I don't think we need to
do is find the the mlst tool lucas
acidity so again in the macro wikinomics
module so 2jgstl see and identify key to
this tool and we need to select the the
double realigned mapping file if you can
see it's local design locally realign so
we will use that
and we need to select our demo 15
and as you can see here we can select
when the tool will are reported or
coverage and as a default it's set to 30
for workers this is 50 more
David results in the amount a formal
okay finish
a so
as you can see it now Columbus for the
warning that there was a little coverage
region so if we find the NGS and I'm
super cool
then you can see that at the top we have
salary
after this also this particular iPod at
most a sequence license in you can see
that all of the different genes and
phenomena analyzed in the screen and you
can see see a little number and also the
low coverage so you can also go and view
the individual happening at each of the
MLS kilo sign I won't do this now but it
is it is possible
so going back to the show
so the next thing we want to do with our
service is to investigate if they could
form part of the same outbreak so as you
might remember from the first analysis
we did identifying the taxonomy of the
incidence I will concede from those
results that they do not belong to the
same clade so therefore the file has not
been mapped to the same reference and in
order to perform an outbreak analysis
using a snip we need all of the files to
be mapped to the same reference so for
this analysis the first thing we need to
do is to identify a common reference or
all of the isolates and we will do that
by calculating Akemi troops then from
that selected color reference we will
Mak our
reads from the five isolates after the
same reference would call the variants
and then we will create a snip tree
based on the results of these analysis I
will be adentro Graham on which we can
display different layers of metadata
so again going back to the to the 2-0
okay so here we go
so the first thing we need to do is
define a common reference and we will
produce a chemistry based on our trade
routes and the list of WLAN reference
genomes
so going again to the tool box down here
we have a creative community tool don't
we open that
then we need to select our trim crease
and we also need to collect some someone
and a reference image for the tool to
measure the gang
so we need to specify the results
metadata table I know that so too long
to link the results to our metadata and
the input
I see it and again artists I just quit
water
and we will see
now here you can see the process so it's
just
the different came individually from
in what is
a short time
here we have the results of chemistry
and if we open this
then you can see that the potential
outbreak I saw the one named er so we
have two outbreak I put it up here and
we have three down here in this cluster
and we will collect this genome as the
reference genome for for further
analysis
so we can now close the Kami tree and
what we want to do now is using this
common reference we want to map the
individual retail to this reference so
we have created a workflow that will do
this and also colors and
we go to this work flow shoulder and we
select this map specify reference and if
we open a copy of it it will open and we
can visualize what it will do so I start
by trimming the reeds we have always
done left those that it doesn't matter
then it will wrap the recently reference
it will it will improve on the mapping
using yokas realignment and it will also
perform some basic variant protection so
we double click on them the tool studied
and that reads the reference we can
specify the reference and as a shorter
makinia tree it was this reference
several successes matched you want to be
outbreak methods
click finish so that what we face now
adapt to the setting that this is the
reference you want to use and then we
need to specify where it should put a
where should link on of the top sciences
so the result negative table we just
need to tell it where this is located
the final thing we need to do is to save
the workflow so we must say the couple
if it's not just put it in the app
excellent ok so now we are ready to run
the webshop so you can go to the results
metadata table
make sure we have a lot of absorb in
there and then we can if you go to the
to the road and then find our kindred
the next
five trim good then we can stay with
selector and then we can say run copy of
map to fit advice
then from here we gotta repeat the word
sure so as you can see up here on the
left this is always all of the different
stores explore data we can specify what
parameters and it has already because we
selected refile indeed result me to be
stable this is already been selected
this can be an advantage if you are
working with many many isolates and it
is an easy way to find you and the
faulty one about this
so we need to kick the batch option and
then just go through the discipline up
so as you can see there is something we
to be disabled so it is perfect right
these are the trimming pramana are the
reference for the down rapid a reference
tool has already been selected and we
will just good acidity and then we need
to specify one of these as it's not fast
in the outfit for
the only thing you need to be aware of
is such as if you wanna run stop work
flows directly from there the Shelf
metadata they will copy us the work show
needs to be open in the view
otherwise it won't recognize it
so we can go to the spa
see how we are doing doing on that
so one of the outputs from from this
cell which workflow metric certified
reference is the list of variants
between each of these three files for
the different isolates and gather and
become a reference of your medicine and
these variants will then be inputs for
us to create our countries
this will be fun run socialize but
so you think the mystery compared to
these painting trees by the tech tree
multi-piece are much higher resolution
in your egg analysis that it's based on
the individual differences between
languages so you will get a very high
resolution on your outfit out of this 24
in the tree
if you can see that all of those are so
fast
and added to the outbreak to sort of
these creative people
as you can see what it will seduce is
so it will different have a true indigo
which we have already looked at when we
use swimming through individual time and
it has nothing from the local
realignment of it taking into account
our Fitness we have a mapping services
and we have use um variant forms
so we are almost through syphilis
waiting on the last set of the sauce
once it's done sauce
we will find the results in the salt-
table
and Sal analysis
okay so we're done so we click have a
fresh if you get number of times five is
an added to the result negative table so
it goes to the throttle of us that's a
quick formal then we can say sales of
remap citrus so this will now only show
us in valves that are valid for victory
creation so as you can see the you have
so we have five back controls and below
we have five variant cells that we want
select form then file choose for each
address and we will say with selective
create citrus so this will start for two
or three country I'll show you when it's
running I'll show you where to the
planet and if you can see because we
started this from there sort of
innovative favor the business is already
from the selector the variant tracks
have already been pre-selected there is
not military since it's not really the
people has also seen detective so we
will choose the maximum likelihood
algorithm and for the nucleotide
substitution not on we were choose to HK
1 we will also like the tool to perform
a good stress analysis
if you are interested in looking at the
exact number of clip differences between
any two either you can help to create
hit metrics and up with it but we will
just leave our the tree in the output
folder
so I go to the toolbox market is working
you can see here the disc ago became
your true we also have a stronger
Christmas tree if you want to if you
prefer to start the tool from there from
toolbox
Hey so our nutritionist in chrismole oh
okay
this is what it looks like
and over here on the right we have a
metadata set and if you go to the bottom
of that decimated metadata layer and we
can specify a number of metadata there
so for example if you want to play the
outbreak number so you can see that blue
color
that's a nice edge from a hospital the
green I select asana practice grower at
that where I put it powerful strong and
now we can ask as many metadata asleep
as we'd like so we could also if to
display the server type which was an add
another widget in it if you really don't
like green you can double click on the
other Green Square in there in the
metadata they are done selecting the
color you like
change it to whatever you like and you
can also change the layout of your
dental gram whatever you like
okay so we'll now go back to the
presentation for the final thoughts
okay so the last part we want to detect
NEX microbial resistance genes in the
genomes of these five Salmonella and
pestle it so the insert for how this
tool will be the trend read or actually
it will be it will be context so we will
need to use trim reads to produce a de
novo assembly we will also need to
download the database no resistance gene
and then we will use the find assistance
tool which is based on restaurant
developed ionic energy to do the
research on this message will be a list
of identified persistent scene for each
feed input items I'll just go back to to
the workbench again
okay so as I mentioned we will need to
do it over assembly to produce conflict
and the high persistence tool required
to either the Network Encino a genome or
list of contexts
so for that we will go to toolbox and we
will find our global sequencing to know
we're sampling
and we will select our we'll select
option three there we go
I was in lunches rocked the batch option
and just need to make sure here that we
click the option to create similar
complex justice assistance
and let's create another folder here the
results
ha ha actually assistance
the one piece is running we can download
the database of known patrollers
distinction
Olimpico who are the bullet with tours
for the macro business module and then
go to
to the database model functional
analysis and then download database to
find fixes
this thing
put it in our new folder this will
download the database directly from
countries did you use the databases
panelist fantasy
the girl checks complete disaster
database down
okay now you can see here that now we
have found a database provide the system
and again this is also been lost with
the base that is has been downloaded so
that we can always keep track on which
mesh and off to the database where you
have been working
so
listen good start the tool for one of
these sell for silicon
we'll find the tool called fired
assistance please opens up
and
then selects but it's a classic that was
produced by leaden over substance
I'm going to specify the fate of ice at
the school she refused
this is the best coffee fault and then
save themselves
and shouldn't be here this was a great
outcome that is the table of any other
society physician is it open that we can
see that the content of this channel is
and this identifies genes in this
particular accident are we can see the
surprise identity to the reference of a
database I'm going to confuse a pretty
good phenotype so that it's microbial
resistance genes we can also see in the
last one that we have an accession
number so this is a direct link to the
bad accession and CDI so that this thing
will take you directly to us thank you
guys
so just going back to
again
okay so we forgot through all of the
steps to our science academy to isolate
find the sequence I'd find a bar markers
and investigating the phylogenetic
relationships of the excellence and as
you have seen this requires quite a
number of tools so to make it easier
access that you run all of these
analyses in one go we have collected the
tools but their needs in virtual
so
this workflow will find the the best
matches it will I get society it will
call variants ready for this mystery and
it would also start the fire resistance
tool and then output all of the soap
files that you need
so the wordpress can either be started
from a single number or as a batch
processing and I will show you the
difference when we go back to the
workbench in a minute and so the
advantages of using these workflows is
it's easy to get started now it will
save you time and running it because you
will not have to go back and start
individual tool now you can run some
holes attachment and it will also ensure
that you have a consistency in all of
your problem setting so you can stop for
workflows and share with colleagues and
make sure that that you all produced
results in my family
so if we go back to the live demo
okay yeah
so going back to the tool box and if the
typing and if you give er a folder and
let's take a look at at the workflows
so there are two ways of setting of what
you'll see you can either don't click on
the icon and this will take you through
a wizard where you can specify the
parameters for all of the individual
tools that we're running in this
workflow however if you want to run more
than one set up all of the - you will
need to right-click and stay open copy
of workflow
and it will open a workflow like this
and you will need to specify down here
in the green don't click on it sort
metadata stable and specify where you
save that in the folder structure so it
so the workflow will know where to
output your results so everything else
can be happy all of the other parameters
specified along the way but if you want
to create a workflow with all of the
settings locks you can just click on any
tool here double click and then specify
your parameters you can also see what
the little locks in you can talk any
parameter that you don't want anyone
else to handle with
that I think you need to do before that
Ramabai troll is just completed
so then you can attach it before you can
go to do the result immediately disable
and you can find it's just remove the
clips on there and then you can
you can select your your input read file
so these are the main ones that I need
samples and then you can from this this
table you can start the virtual so I
won't start the workflow because
obviously it will go through all of the
steps we've just gone through learning
and it will take time that I will just
show you I have computed this already
and I just want to highlight
go to and open the results metadata
table that has been could useful filled
in with this
from this language workflow this dance
pad all the data you can see the
workload a little could use Rs 55 the
source time so up here in the top you
will have F you shall perform we will
have one of the specified metadata so
the ID for the sequencing file has the
outfit number but what you will also
have and this is one of the major
advantages of running or virtual and
linking it to the result readability is
that it will also produce a summary of
your results so here you can see the
results from the cash match and Alice's
so you think a missile and you can see
much clearer here now that these effects
are all mapping to different references
you can see
CEO as it stops from the contamination
reporter gives each one of the absolute
had a contamination with the thorium and
we can also find the amount of cheer
results and we can find results from the
air from the antimicrobial resistance
finding tool this will create a summary
and you can directly go through each of
the different results and from this
table
just go the final gun go back to to the
prepetition
okay so if this is further address you
can go to our website at www.tanahoy.com
and download a free trial are successful
so to perform this analysis you will
need to download those the CMC genomics
workbench and the plug-in the CMC
microbrews in our module at the website
you can also find a brain of a step by
step tutorial and video tutorial showing
how to use many of the functionalities
within the word patient module and so
with that I want in this presentation
and I will thank you for watching thank
you
Thank You dr. Ritter Berg for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is is it possible to
get data and results out of the CLC
software for example for making
graphical representations or tables
thank you for that question yes any
tables and any graphical output can be
exported in all standard format so for
example if you want to export a table
that you can use for a software for
someone exported to excel you can export
it SS it's a standard CSV file and all
of the graphics can be exported at any
standard imaging file
and it looks like we have time for one
more question if I have analyzed a group
of outbreak isolates and then at a later
time point discover an isolate that I
suspect to belong to the same outbreak
do I need to perform all analysis over
again and to include this new isolate
now if you have used the the result
metadata table you can in your in your
original metadata file you will just add
information on that one new isolate that
you wish to include in the analysis the
network will link to the result metadata
table and then you can run analysis or
just that one isolate and then the other
thing you would need to relearn would be
the snip tree to to also include the
isolate and the magenta graph to get a
visual of where that new life of the
last with with the outbreak or the
original string
I would like to once again thank dr.
Ritter Berg for her presentation I would
also like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor kaya Jen making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2018
you will receive an email from labyrinth
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon
goodbye